[Musica]
ma anche vitale zino ciao lenza
grandissimo richiesto siccome avete
lasciato tantissimi dai trascorsa
challenge era alexa contro stili questa
volta ci sarà alessia contro google
vediamo chi vincerà vediamo che farà
molto bello
vediamo chi sarà più cattivo vediamo che
ingredienti sceglieranno chi sarà il più
tolto di progetto per imboccare il primo
round innanzitutto dobbiamo vedere a chi
capta letta ea chicca sui crabs un collo
che quindi pure che facciamo noi carta
forbice tra chi vince fa la corsa a
forbice su cona lezza da vinci contro
l'ex premier ex se perdi aprendo io con
l'altra persona la carta fatto a letta
tasso carta forbice ok giochiamo 321
forbice
dobbiamo rifarla all extra sasso carta
forbice ok giochiamo 321 sasso
[Applauso]
roba insomma si sente quello che è un po
lento ma non avete visto abbiamo anche
fatto una challenge tv contro
l'assistente google se non lo avete
visto vivete link alla fine di questo
video e nei commenti così voi potete
andare a vedere
indovinate chi vince in 2008 and
iniziamo con i coloranti
[Musica]
quindi vediamo chi inizia carta fare
successo carta politica
sapete che a next è un po più
intelligente quindi posso chiedere
direttamente il colore in questo numero
perché alexa all eta di un colore a caso
gentle indiano
bello altrove con la volta che giorno al
marrone foca da starter appaiano nel
cielo finora nota stonata bravas poi
vediamo che per di capitanata dopo
quindi adesso io via da 60 google i o di
un numero a caso non trovo una 61 stata
fatta una slide prosa che fortuna
effetto giallo indiano
allora mette più bellissimo giallo
indiano la mediana cup e speriamo che
non si rovinerà dopo con gli altri
colori d'ischia mischiamo è sì un bel
giallo glossy mista
ma tanto so già che non rimarrà così
perché era vero che bella finora è
bellissima se avete un po di rosso
diventa parlare ma poi certe come dire
finalmente posso mettere il mio rosa
glitterato ma che belli ma meglio così
almeno più e più con un atlante da
foschi ti rovini assicurare no guarda
ignazio è no ma dobbiamo mettere di più
perché guarda veniva preso bianco la
quasi assorbito tutto venezia lo
vogliamo più rosa la fragolina to go
round abbiamo i nostri pigmenti che
potrebbero cambiare completamente il
colore o migliorarlo guarda critici
verde e coraggio dite marocchino in
bronzo bronzo reja utilizza carta fu
arrestato la carta fuori scasso che se
fosse stato sempre il giornale fa scegli
un colore a caso ben felice byte lo devi
capire alex è così ma che ca o best
potrebbe essere questo mi avete bianco
questo non abbiamo nessun ben guardare
lo dico tutta italia questo e beige è un
pochino a nordest
sono arrivati suo pezzo forse questo un
po peggio dobbiamo tagliare la carezza
fatto che non abbiamo detto tutto alexa
è di un colore a caso rosso credo di no
lì il rosso cardinale forse questo
insomma rosso cardinale dopo un
rossiccio arancione ma è l'unico che si
avvicina il colore marrone truccate ma
guai a fatti sono 24 sentire 89 sceglie
un numero a caso tra 1 e 9 4 4 1 2 3 4
par ritiro c'è un piccolo che sia questo
in realtà non mi sembra pronto a si è
pronto perché ho detto no
allora vediamo subito come questo rosso
cardinale colore del mio team è una
specie di rossiccio arancione piquet
rossi cardinale e siamo tutti in attesa
che diventi marrone per la serba figuro
no
che bel colore per dire che bello adesso
vedrai una mischia non è vero è ancora
bello e ancora un po crunch ha visto che
colore stia diventando bastardo non è
vero è un giallo e un è un giorno scuro
scuro è un diventato tipo un arancione
chiaro chiaro male noi disco mi auguro
ragione carugate legislatura scrivete
voi nei commenti che colore è questo
secondo voi come diretta con il tuo zio
l'idea secondo me questo non è bronzo e
rosa rosa e no terra diventa bellissima
per grazie rosa sembrano il secondo più
rumorosa e brindiamo girone marrone rose
gold impreziosendo in preziosi ad ora
era gli ho detto che fortuna è rimasto
rosa nonostante tu abbia queste parole
non è marrone e gli ho detto è qui la
rose gold infatti è bellissimo guarda
ora che è stupendo niente cosa si vede
si vede rosa la prosa poi ci aggiunge in
porto perché te lo immagini
abbiamo qua la lozione la schiuma da
barba e la cosa più bella
purtroppo si stima che anche
profumatissimo sono anche loro domande
siamo anche la stima di peppa carta
parli di carta ho fatto io
speriamo che sembra stretti alexa scegli
un numero a caso tra 1 e 3 bigamia
tornerà giallo grazie a google scelto il
numero a caso tra uno e due nella
profumata e almeno titoli dopo il mio
slideview e rosa ma la nazione bianca e
che certo
mettiamo la virtus ha detto infatti
bisogna stare attenti con l'ultimo di
probabile se ne mette troppo a
strapparla è neanche un po difficile da
mischiare però una sun sistenza regali
finissima perché è simbolo che non vanno
mai più soli dovesse rimanere sintesi un
po puoi fare tutte le forme perché in
teoria e io dico schiuma da barba ma non
può essere una schiuma da barba perché
non penso che un uomo adulto si basa la
barba una barba se io state in realtà è
un sapone schiumoso che si può usare nel
bagno quando fa il bagno è perché si usa
questo che speciale perché in pratica
vedete che a questa consistenza un po
dura e quindi con le mani si può si
possono fare le varie forme quindi
l'anno e non ce ne frega niente e lo
usiamo per lo slide l'acqua si stava
scavando adesso guardate con quel
morbido questo farà un sacco di bolle un
sacco di sony non vedo l'ora di sentire
i suoni non vado nella di attivarlo
oddio quanto colore adesso sperando che
i prossimi ingredienti non lo
rovineranno per ora mi piace
non è vero sarà più elastico mettendo
l'adozione e la profuma un po almeno è
sì che basta proclami famiglie
ok pronti allora non si vedono bene ma
abbiamo tutte differenza abbiamo un
sacco di pallini dieci chef e vediamo
chi inizia prima poi carta poi lo stato
c'è qualcosa di strano ma solo in forma
viene allora questa volta siccome ci
sono anche cose multicolor tifo queste
palline che su facebook ad alexa
chiediamo il numero invece del colore
fra quanti sono 10 2 4 6 8 10 figli
alexa se il numero a caso tra 1 e 10 9
[Musica]
vediamo che avvitare capiterà bis molo
pur questi twitter che non gli piace noi
siamo liguri sceglie un numero a caso
tra 1 e 9
bastano che nessuno hanno beccato la
maledizione del verde ancora guardato in
fano per i glitter che lui odia verdi
che non c'entra niente col tolosa attiri
i titoli che farà dei rumori fantastici
issimi in più tour e le palline insomma
sarà una sorta di belle dei kage davvero
bellissimo questo qui poi su quel colore
lei è proprio una torta test proprio
berdych
[Musica]
finalmente sono stato fortunato tutto
grazie ad aversa e bellissimo l'assetto
di tutti i colori sembrano tanti
confetti colorati caramellati più
l'impasto della torta tutto profuma
robbie permettono il forno non vedo
volete vedere come sarà attivato tra il
fantastico
vediamo ora quella di vitale
[Musica]
ok allora ultimo abbiamo tantissimi
vediamo si inizia vediamo se vinco
nuvolette cartapesta di un primato da
google
dimmi un numero a caso tra 118 certo
ecco qui 18
[Applauso]
la città ti capita praticamente che il
grigio sono stato fortunatissimo questa
sale la città di e speriamo che guardati
bene ancora non solo triste perché sono
un po me perché nel web ci sta bene il
nel rosa ci sta bene un po di glitter
nero sì perché si vedono adesso vedrai
vedrai libere il verbo è stato un po
risucchiato quindi quando mi ha detto
che stanno bene
mandiamo alexsander serie a me tu hai
detto
alexa stop tu hai detto che tu hai detto
che non che non ti è capitato al correr
verde e che sei stato super fortunato
però adesso c'è l'ultimo round pd non si
possa tenere solo che ti dice qualcosa
cosa vuoi dire un mistero e auspica che
vive per beppe crediamo alexa scegli un
colore a caso chartreuse che sarebbe un
liquore francese che indovina di che
colore è la chartreuse che core
trasporto
no sono spazio verde paolo 60 della
chart rosso ma perché non puoi scegliere
un colore normale spiega ma l'ex a cerca
chartreuse su rigide ecco un articolo di
will be glass chartreuse e il rumore la
chartreuse è un liquido prodotto in
origine dai monaci certosini nelle
cantine della certosa grande chartreuse
situata nelle prealpi della scelta osavo
i rom nel dipartimento dell'isère nella
francia meridionale la chartreuse nacque
nel 1605 quando i monaci certosini di
won vert nel luogo dell'attuale giardino
dello cyborg rimisero hanno scritto con
la formula di un
di lunga vita la chartreuse deve né
invece lavorato nel 1764 della
rivoluzione francese i monaci volendo
conservare la ricetta la videro al
farmacista degree novoli aiutare la
ricerca tornerai buona c'è la sua morte
nel 1816 lascia cruz della fu
commercializzata per la prima volta nel
1800 1900
come potete vedere la chartreuse a che
si vede è verde e il giallo che il verde
ma farò finta che c'è sono belli e vero
c'è che giallo però sono tutti capitolo
risulta colpa di a lei tifa capito
questa cosa come sperate
[Applauso]
secondo me il concert rosa e questo
quindi ti prendi questo che è verde
allora mettiamo il mio verde certo la
maledizione del vertice informale
altopianese la colpa di arezzo sui
colori strambino pescare ancora è
normale che detto rosa arancione o rosso
invece chartreuse o dietro l'altro si
vede un sacco perché si vede così tanto
questo vero perché vi sta bene
no ho rovinato il mio colore giallo
sembra vitale
ecco perché non mi piace il bar degli
slide perché sembra buffa ciao creavamo
fidati che peccato ma rovinato un sacco
concordo siamo come rovinerà il secondo
me ci sta bene perché sul rosa per il
gravissimo tra l'altro lo rovinano
provino a porta che bello si vedono
tutti i glitter guardo si vedono gli i
bottini i puntini del grigio come le
fragole sembrano con una fragola non ci
sente che le frane lo chiamano tutti
quei punti 66 metti sì sì questo pilot
slime fragola ormai giudicato ok allora
ora abbiamo vinto degli ingredienti e
motivarlo e poi li possono vedere
dovrete votare per bellezza e purezza
emersi tre slam
alla fine fortunatamente è uscito una
specie di giallo e kramer e un po sacco
di pallini giallo giallo bomb scuro e
l'inter verdi l'anno un pochino rovinato
purtroppo però fa un bel posizioni in
realtà mi è caduto un po troppo
bicarbonato purtroppo perché quando lo
scavo attivando ho messo questo
contenitore qua ma me ne caduto un po
troppo quindi si è attivato purtroppo
però mi piace lo stesso era bello
famosissimo e ora si è disunito un
pochino
quindi questo è il bios vari preghiamo
quello digitale
poi così evitare
carino è un po sciolto invece quello io
mi piaceva davvero tirato troppo
che bello il colore più si vedono tutti
i consideriamo noi di click e l'iter
greaves ii il verde il bertolino di quei
flakes invece quasi quasi del tutto
scomparso c è molto morbido ed elastico
il colore mi piace tantissimo questo
rosa chiaro quasi antico e guardate
super morbido la lozione era tenuto
abbastanza morbido
sono proprio contento del mio slime
quale vince secondo voi
quotate quello di vitale verde che si
chiama fra le mani una cosa che si
chiama slide fragile
ma la fortuna non solo allora muta dei
risultati servizio tv resta ottimo 4
cartellini puoi cliccare per vedere le
nostre altri soldi nuovi video cliccate
scuola che i propri di tempo
ciao